FIRST, AND THE VIRUS.
WE TORE THE LID OFF A SERIES,
THE PANDEMIC’S FALL OUT, THOUGH
OF COURSE EXTREMELY TRAGIC COULD
HAVE BEEN FAR WORSE, HAD HE NOT
SHUT DOWN TRAVEL EARLY AND
REOPENED THE ECONOMY WHEN NEEDED
NEEDED.
HOSPITAL SYSTEMS IN A FEW STATES
WERE STRETCHED BUT NOT
OVERWHELMED.
GIVEN THE DEMOCRAT’S CONSTANTLY
WAILING ABOUT WHAT TRUMP
SUPPOSEDLY GOT WRONG, WE DECIDED
TO SKETCH OUT WHAT THE SITUATION
WOULD’VE LOOKED LIKE HAD
JOE BIDEN AND THE DEMOCRATS BEEN
IN CHARGE INSTEAD.
FIRST, BIDEN WOULD NOT HAVE BAND
TRAVEL FROM CHINA.
THERE IS NO WAY HE WOULD HAVE
DONE THAT, TWO MONTHS AFTER
TRUMP DID JUST THAT, BIDEN WAS
STILL WORRYING ABOUT HURTING
CHINA’S’ CEILINGS.
>> BEING OVERLY DISMISSIVE ARE
SPREADING DISINFORMATION IS
GOING TO HURT US AND FURTHER
ADVANTAGE OF THE SPREAD OF THE
DISEASE.
NEITHER SHOULD WE PANIC OR FALL
BACK ON XENOPHOBIA, LABELING
COVID-19 A FOREIGN VIRUS DOES
NOT DISPLACE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THE MISPLACED JUDGMENT SO FAR.
>> Laura: HE WAS WORRIED ABOUT
XENOPHOBIA, NOT THE VIRUS.
HE WOULD HAVE EFFECTIVELY
REWARDED THE CCP FOR UNLEASHING
THIS PLAGUE BY ALLOWING THEM TO
CONTINUE TO STEAL OUR TRADE
SECRETS AND TO TAKE OUR JOBS.
IT’S CLEAR THAT UNDER BIDEN
THERE WOULD BE NO TARIFFS AND
THUS, NO CHINESE CONCESSION.
>> SOMEONE SAID TO THE TRUMP
STANCE IS A GOOD ONE TO COUNTER
CHINESE INFLUENCE, WOULD YOU
KEEP THE TARIFFS?
>> NO.
HEY, LOOK.
WHO SAID TRUMP’S IDEA IS A GOOD
ONE?
SPEED WHEN HE WOULD GET RID OF
THE TARIFFS, DAY ONE.
A BIDEN PRESIDENCY IS A DREAM
SCENARIO FOR THE CCP AND GIVEN
THAT THE W.H.O. HAS BEEN PIMPING
FROM CHINA FOR YEARS, HOW WOULD
THAT HELP?
UNDER BIDEN, AS UNDER OBAMA,
EUROPE’S FEELINGS ON A TRAVEL
BAN WOULD HAVE BEEN MORE
IMPORTANT THAN WHAT WAS GOOD FOR
AMERICANS.
HEAVEN FORBID, CAN’T OFFEND THE
FRENCH.
>> BANNING ALL TRAVEL FROM
EUROPE MAY SLOW IT BUT AS WE’VE
SEEN, IT WILL NOT STOP IT AND
TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS BASED ON
FAVORITISM AND POLITICS RATHER
THAN RISK WILL BE
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
>> Laura: YOU CAN’T MAKE THIS
UP.
AND UNDER BIDEN, ILLEGALS, THEY
WOULD KEEP POURING IN AND FORGET
RAMPED UP BORDER ENFORCEMENT
UNDER BIDEN AS AT ALL.
EVEN EUROPEAN COUNTRIES LIKE
GERMANY LOCKED DOWN THEIR
BORDERS BUT JOE WOULD EVER EVEN
CONSIDER A CRACKDOWN ON ILLEGAL
BORDER CROSSINGS EVEN DURING A
PANDEMIC, HE OPENED THE ICE
PIECE FACILITIES, RELEASE ALL
DETAINEES AND THEN ASK QUESTIONS
LATER.
AFTER ALL, WHAT WOULD JORGE
RAMOS SAY?
>> TRUMP CAMPAIGN DON "BUILD
THAT WALL," ARE YOU WILLING TO
TEAR THAT WALL DOWN?
>> THERE WILL NOT BE ANOTHER
FOOT OF WALL CONSTRUCTED IN MY
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Laura: OF COURSE THE BORDER
FENCE ONTO THE WALLS, THEY ARE
MEANT TO FORCE FOREIGNERS TO
FORMAL POINTS OF ENTRY WHERE WE
CAN AT LEAST DO SOME MINIMAL
SCREENING FOR ILLNESSES BUT
BIDEN WILL ALWAYS CHOOSE OPEN
BORDERS AHEAD OF THE HEALTH,
SAFETY, AND ECONOMIC WELL-BEING
OF AMERICANS.
NUMBER THREE, BIDEN WOULD KEEP
YOU LOCKED DOWN UNTIL AT LEAST
2021.
WHILE HE’S LETTING MILLIONS OF
ILLEGAL ALIENS FLOOD THE LABOR
MARKETS, HE’D MAKE SURE YOU ARE
STILL LOCKED DOWN IN YOUR HOME
AND YOUR KIDS ARE OUT OF SCHOOL.
HIS ALLIES AND POLITICS IN THE
PRESS, WHO ARE MESSAGING BIDEN’S
PLANS, THEY SPILLED THE BEANS.
>> IF YOU’RE NOT GOING TO STAY
HOME AND WEAR MASKS IN PUBLIC,
WE HAVE TO ENFORCE AND WE WILL.
>> THIS WOULD’VE BEEN A VERY
DIFFERENT SUMMARY IF WE’D HAD A
BETTER LOCKED DOWN, A LONGER
LOCKED DOWN.
>> ANY CONCERN THAT YOU’VE GONE
TOO FAR IN ANY WAY WITH THE DATE
HOME RESTRICTIONS >> NO.
>> Laura: AND BIDEN HINTED AT
THIS HIMSELF JUST LAST WEEK.
>> FROM THE BEGINNING, IN MY
VIEW, THE PRESIDENT HAS GIVEN US
A FALSE CHOICE.
HE SAID THAT WE HAVE TO GET BACK
TO WORK AND ALSO DEAL WITH
COVID.
YOU CAN’T GET THIS COUNTRY GOING
AGAIN UNLESS YOU GET COVID UNDER
CONTROL.
>> Laura: YOU KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS, NUMBER FOUR.
BIDEN’S LOCKDOWNS WOULD
OBLITERATE THE RECOVERY.
THE COST OF TAKING THE COUNTRY
BACK IN THE LOCKDOWN WOULD BE
STAGGERING.
>> THIS IDEA, PEOPLE JUST THROW
THIS OUT WILLY-NILLY FORGETTING
THE ENORMOUS HUMAN COST AS WELL
AS THE ENORMOUS ECONOMIC COST,
THE COUNTRY CAN’T TAKE THAT AND
THERE IS NO REASON FOR THAT.
>> Laura: BIDEN’S LOCKDOWNS
WOULD ALSO LEAD TO MORE HEALTH
CRISES.
EVEN WITH A LIMITED TEMPORARY
LOCKDOWN THINGS WERE BAD,
IMAGINE IF IT HAD CONTINUED
THROUGH MOST OF THE YEAR PAY
LAST MONTH "THE WASHINGTON POST"
REPORTED THAT SUSPECTED
OVERDOSES NATIONALLY JUMPED 18%
IN MARCH, 29% IN APRIL AND 42%
IN MAY.
AND LOCKDOWNS AROUND THE WORLD
ARE LEADING TO A RESURGENCE OF
THINGS LIKE TUBERCULOSIS, HIV,
AND MALARIA.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTING
THAT A THREE-MONTH LOCKDOWN
ACROSS DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
WORLD AND A GRADUAL RETURN TO
NORMAL OVER TEN MONTHS COULD
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL 6.3 MILLION
CASES OF TB, 1.4 MILLION DEATHS.
IN THE WORST-CASE SCENARIO
SCENARIO, DEATHS FROM MALARIA
COULD DOUBLE TO 770,000 PER
YEAR.
NUMBER SIX.
BIDEN WOULD USE THE PANDEMIC
CHAIR RAN THROUGH FAR LEFT
POLICIES.
AND OF COURSE THE OLD SAYING,
NEVER LET CRISIS GO TO WASTE
WOULD BE BIDEN’S PANDEMIC MOTTO.
>> AND I TRULY THINK THAT IF WE
DO THIS RIGHT, WE HAVE AN
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY TO NOT
JUST DIG OUT OF THIS CRISIS BUT
TO FUNDAMENTALLY TRANSFORM THE
COUNTRY.
>> Laura: WOULDN’T BE A
COUNTRY LEFT.
WE ALL KNOW THAT MEANS, RAMMING
THROUGH EVERY SOCIALIST WISH
LIST ITEM.
EMPTY OF THE PRISONS,
SINGLE-PAYER HEALTH CARE,
GOVERNMENT PAID CHILD CARE, THE
GREEN NEW DEAL, GUARANTEED BASIC
INCOME AND OF COURSE,
REPARATIONS.
AND WHILE PRESIDENT BIDEN WENT
ABOUT TRANSFORMING OUR COUNTRY,
HE’D OF COURSE GET A FREE PASS
FROM THE MEDIA.
NO ANTAGONISTIC INTERVIEWS WITH
AXIOS, NO AGGRESSIVE QUESTIONING
FROM JIM ACOSTA, JUST A LOT OF
GAUZY PROFILES ABOUT HIS
VICE PRESIDENT AND HOW SHE’S THE
FIRST AND SHE’S ALSO A GLOBAL
SUPERSTAR.
THIS LAUNDRY LIST OF HORRIBLE’S
SHOULD MAKE ALL AMERICANS THINK
ABOUT VOTING FOR CHANGE THINK
TWICE ABOUT IT IN NOVEMBER.
GIVEN THE VIOLENCE IN THE
STREETS AND THE RETURN OF THE
DEMOCRATS, THE TYPE OF HOME AND
CHANGE THAT OBAMA PROMISED 12
YEARS AGO, IT WOULD BE FAR MORE
RADICAL AND NOW THERE IS FAR
MORE AT STAKE.
BUT THEY HOPE THEIR ALLIES AND
THEIR MISDIRECTION WILL MAKE YOU
FORGET ABOUT THE UNPARALLELED
PROSPERITY THAT WE ENJOYED
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC HIT IN WHAT
WE ARE ON OUR WAY TO SEE AGAIN
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WOULD YOU RATHER GO BACK TO THAT
NORMAL OR EXPERIENCE THE NEW
NORMAL, THE DEMOCRATS ARE GIVING
US A GLIMPSE OF IN CALIFORNIA
AND IN NEW YORK AND ON THE
STREETS OF CHICAGO AND BALTIMORE
BALTIMORE.
IN JOE’S NEW SOCIETY, YOU WILL
BE POORER, LESS SAFE, LESS FREE,
AND YOUR KIDS WILL BE LESS
EDUCATED AND AT THAT POINT, OF